welcome back to las vegas now it is time
for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca and she
brought along someone who needs a safe
kind great home i hear we have molly
look at this cutie this is molly oh my
gosh so cute
so cute molly's a five-year-old
chihuahua mix and she's
so sweet she's actually kind of a little
diva she's a princess i love that
she's so cute she's got the cute little
ears um so we would love to find her the
the best home ever because she deserves
it and she's so sweet you know she came
into the shelter um
pretty underweight um so we're working
to fatten her up and get her really
healthy but she's she's ready for her
loving new home
so we gotta find the right person for
her definitely and what is the right
home for
a dog like molly sure so molly since
we've been here
we you know she would probably be best
as the only dog or
could potentially be with another dog
her size just a little dog she's a
little bit
skittish a little fearful so you got to
kind of go a little bit slow um getting
to know her she
does prefer women but um you know just
go slow with her but she
would be best with teenagers um and
adults preferably
okay but it's just a sweetheart she's so
cute so spunky and she loves
her treats lovable diva right amy
and you mentioned earlier um you're
doing a curbside
you guys have curbside now because of
new regulations for covid
let's talk about that really quick
absolutely so what you're going to do is
when you book an appointment
online on our website you're actually
going to get a phone consultation with
one of our adoption counselors
who will go through everything about the
animal that you're interested in and
inquiring about um and if that is a good
fit we will actually bring that animal
out to you
curbside so that we keep people outside
of the shelter and sort of minimize any
risk that is associated with covid
perfect well thank you amy for keeping
the dogs and the owners and all the pets
safe
thank you so much all right if you're
interested in adopting a pet go to
nevada nevadaspca.org or just call them
at 702-873-7722